we're pre-vetting
our corporate for the startups 100
because again we realize that their most
important asset is their time yeah
um and in the end it creates a a win-win
for everyone because we didn't waste the
time of the business unit not for the
startups and not for us as well
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j-ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this is a
very very special episode an amazing
friend of mine orameri from procter
gamble is coming to talk to us about
innovation and not just innovation in
the simple terms of the word but
innovation within corporation innovation
and how startups can integrate into
these large corporates and what really
opportunities lie in this intersection
always the global tech innovator
director at procter gamble his key goal
is to create a sustainable competitive
advantage for png by partnering with top
entrepreneurs vcs and researchers
worldwide in order to incorporate their
disruptive technologies within png
global business units
his broad span of interests include
cyber security data analytics enterprise
infrastructure industry 4.0
sustainability and more
a former accountant or serves as a board
member in startups and non-profit
organizations alike additionally he is
the co-host of the digital transformers
podcast where he interviews those who
lead innovation at large multinational
corporates
oh amazing welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you doing very much how are you
i'm doing amazing i've been waiting for
this for so long same here and you know
we've been working together sometimes
but we've been friends for a much longer
time than we've been working together
and right you know your work is so
fascinating within png but i think that
you found yourself at some really
interesting intersections in the tech
ecosystem and the social ecosystem
which are not trivial at all and you're
you're both working for for an
incredible company that is responsible
for many of the products we use in our
day today yet you're really deeply
rooted into the the tech ecosystem and
the innovation side of it on the
investment side of it the advising side
of it and so i'm curious to hear about
sort of the submerge of the two right
and what's been happening here and a
little bit what you've observed about
you know the real world outside of
what's been happening and so thank you
very very much for being here thanks for
inviting me
so
starting with you a little bit sure
are you a technologist
a an innovative geek well how do you
describe sort of yourself
um i think
i describe myself as an
infinite curious learner
um i'm not a technologist by background
i'm actually an accountant unfortunately
um
but i started actually my role at png
about eight years ago after spending
three years at deloitte and one year at
nestle
and i joined png as the local controller
what does i mean local control uh it
means that i was the one within png
israel that in charge of the accounting
the tax the payroll all that fun stuff
so just to so we're not yet even talking
about innovation startups and we're
literally you're sitting looking at
statements
generating reports financial statements
excel files yep
a little far from a bit just a bit okay
yeah
and uh after a couple of years i
realized that i
i don't want my own human interaction to
be with the tax authorities
and i realized that you know my real
true passion lies with innovation
i started uh my executive mba with
concentration on venture capital i
realized that you know hey i'm based
here in israel the startup nation now
the scale-up nation
and i was really drawn into it
and basically i uh
i scheduled a meeting with the ceo of
png israel and my boss the
cfo and i i was brutally honest with
them and i told you i told them look png
is an amazing company
and by the way i think even more so
nowadays
um
and i just don't see my future as the
next cfo it's not what i care about i
actually got an offer and i told them
about it got an offer to become a cfo at
an external company
and i took the weekend and i thought
about it and i said hey that's not the
the career path that i want to pursue
wow so when was this this was five and a
half years ago more or less yeah
so they told me all right what it is
that you do wanna
wanna do
and i told them that my true passion
lies with innovation and i'd like to
basically um
take the responsibility to lead png's
innovation activities within israel so
wait wait what
i love innovation what does that mean
what what what does innovation can mean
so many different rights innovation
define it yeah innovation is a huge word
and maybe uh overly uh used even in uh
in many cases
but for png at least
innovation and i speak for for my role
it's tech innovation because there are
so many types of innovation there is the
in in companies in cpg consumer packaged
goods companies like png
innovation could mean r d innovation
like product innovation you know uh for
instance our um ariel pods right that
that sort of innovation by itself what
i'm speaking about is tech innovation is
how to basically
work with startups so open innovation
and how to incorporate their disruptive
ideas within procter and gamble was this
something that you experienced in some
way as an accountant to what led to your
to this
internal conviction of saying this is
i'm i'm want to stop this sort of
trajectory and i want to create a new
one for myself right um so i think it's
a combination first of all png israel
had an innovation activity okay um
nowadays i'm talking about like 15 years
ago more or less yeah um
and
that together with my experience in the
in the mba
um
allowed me to basically get exposed to
those
activities and realize that this is
really what i want to do um there's
there's so much talent here and so many
great startups here um that i thought it
would be a shame not to leverage their
uh their capabilities and so still you
you you set out on a mission to to run
innovation take innovation within png
you're exposed to startups mba you're in
the tech scene in israel
why why within png so what and what does
that even mean to run innovation within
one of the largest companies in the
world right so first of all png is is
amazing i think it's it's not often that
you have a chance
to
uh impact the lives of so many people at
png if you know if i compare it to a to
a startup where
combination of 350 unicorns
put together we have 5 billion daily
active users
5 billion daily active users yeah
precisely
it's
right it's quite impressive so the
ability to impact so many people uh it's
it's phenomenal right and so you
understand that you can make an internal
impact which at the end has impact on
others but but still what does you know
what do you envision
as innovation within a company like this
how does innovation even take place
there are so many different uh
possibilities first of all um
implementing ai within png
nowadays ai is implemented in every
different aspect of what we do
many people
don't even think of you know when you
think about ai you don't necessarily
think of png or or cpg companies but ai
is embedded in every and every in each
and every aspect of what we we do
from supply chain to consumer
understanding um to product placement
many different aspects and so your role
as as as a leader in the innovation hub
in the tech scene
how does that work then if you take sort
of more theoretically a company like png
and you take
the likes of startups research et cetera
right what needs to happen for this to
work
so my role is basically to scout and
assess startups all over the world
and connect them to our global business
units and then make sure that we not
only make the connection but the the
solution is also scaled
so basically the way we work is
we work with all the different business
units global business units of png
and whenever it is that they have a
challenge something that they cannot
solve internally or they can but it will
just take too long and too costly they
approach us and they say hey we need
your help
at that stage we're saying
happy to help challenge accepted but
only if you answer three prerequisites
so the first one
first and foremost is
vp approval
the vp approval is crucial because that
allows us to make sure that the business
unit
looks at this challenge as a must-have
versus a nice to have
and that specific question would answer
or would impact the entire um
relationship and the entire project and
so i think that if we can more make we
can do a high level say we need the
agency right we need to know that
there's a there's a the the ability that
if we go into this project we can see to
completion to completion we have the
right agents within the organization
exactly to push this forward we have the
sponsor we have the the leadership uh
support for it and so this i think
answers to a lot of maybe
people's questions about
the bureaucra bureaucratic nature of
doing innovation within a large company
right you're saying that one way to
tackle this is saying we want to see a
streamlined approval from the leadership
team that will mean that we can actually
go and implement this with whatever you
know the budget and the human resources
time etc precisely precisely so i was
speaking about three uh prerequisites so
the first is vp approval yep the second
each is budget for the sake of the poc
now between us i can tell you that yes
we as the innovation arm we have that
budget but we want the business unit to
pay for the poc because we want them to
have skin in the game right
uh and again it all comes
down to the the first uh question is is
it a master very nice day right
completely but by the way i also imagine
when it comes to budget i mean a company
like png that has how many how many
people has one hundred thousand hundred
thousand and and this is a pretty much a
combination of more than 300 unicorns
which essentially means it has a lot of
business and a lot of opportunity right
budget stems from opportunity right if
you present a solution that is
interesting enough and is good enough
anybody will create a budget for it
especially when you technically have
endless resources that you can allocate
right it's just a matter of priorities
exactly so that
that leaves a blue ocean of
opportunities right right because
there's the infrastructure is ready for
you to be utilized exactly and so what's
the third piece so the third piece is
human resource
we realize that you know the most
important asset that the entrepreneurs
have is their time yeah right um
obviously money is important and maybe a
bit more challenging these days but
still
time is the most valuable asset yeah and
we will not accept a situation where the
entrepreneur where she needs to chase
the corporate guy yeah will you know be
willing to uh to do a favor and answer
her emails once every three weeks that's
a big no-no for right right so what we
want to make sure is that the business
unit allocates someone from their team
to be the project owner and more more
than that
it's not only you know just hey yes i'm
the project owner it means that it needs
to be one of their annual goals
meaning this would impact their yearly
bonus right so we want to have on top of
the business incentive we also want to
have the
personal incentive sure and so it sounds
like you're creating this this um
infrastructure or the structure i should
say where you have both skin in the game
you know that you have the potential for
resources right so this idea of budget
is potentially we have the capacity to
deploy right and we have the means of
measuring a person's success given that
they choose this project so once we
chose this now they're going to be
measured by it exactly and that
increases the likelihood of success that
family organization definitely because
you know the the biggest challenge i
think um for many corporates not just us
is the so-called media management yeah
yeah because we have
immense support from from top leaders
sure it's coming all the top from from
the board at our board we have the
tekken innovation committee and the
really the c level and the the cio which
which my group reports to so tons of
support
we have no shortage of leadership
support also if you look at you know the
the the junior or the the entry-level uh
people these are usually younger people
they're very much uh you know usually
they're tech savvy yeah um they're very
much curious and
wanting to to implement and to uh
um to try out new ideas it's mostly the
middle management and
it
they cannot be blamed right these are
people who are experts in in their field
they have been doing
i know a specific process for many years
and it works right so
why now would you like to you know to
try startup or to implement an algorithm
while they they know the the job right
they know how to do it
um so this is the challenge and this is
why we've created this uh personal
incentive and you've been really
innovating in your own role i mean just
by following a lot of the work that
you've been doing the partnerships
creating the the way that you're
structured within this ecosystem you've
really been creating a new type of idea
of what's possible tell me a little bit
about the things that you've done within
png and with the png team that that
really stand out for you sure um
so
most of the the
the job that we're doing is partnerships
right so we're looking to partner with
startups
um to become their uh basically their
uh their clients and
we want to basically uh
implement their technology at a very
relatively early stage because we want
to enjoy the first mover advantage this
is why we're not afraid of you know
being design partners etc so
unfortunately i cannot uh name uh
some of the success stories that we have
in the in the partnership uh area but we
have many and and you know uh some of
them as well a lot in israel a lot in
the us in europe really all over the
place
what i can maybe mention is two
two incense of startups that we've
invested in
so png hasn't invested in startups for
uh over a decade
but in the last year we've made two uh
two investment to equity investments
uh the first is in uh green grin which
is in the tele-dentistry space an
amazing amazing startup
uh and the second is modify um
which is in the scent digitization space
another uh incredible startup yeah
and so you're when you're looking at the
investment in comparison to a
partnership right i mean what what is
the difference from it from a company
like png's perspective right so first of
all it's it's not instead so obviously
we will invest only if there is
you know an
opportunity or possibility to also
partner we are not financial uh
investors by any means sure so the those
investments are only strategic
investments
um
so
only if there's a chance to really you
know um sign a commercial agreement or
to see that there is a benefit for for
both companies and an opportunity to
partner because at the end of the day
when we invest we become partners
so we
we want to make sure that the startup
has uh enjoys the the most successes but
is this investment mostly for it for for
ability to make a larger impact within
the company decision making to
exclusivity potential m a later on
what's sort of the rationale for the
investments there so i would say all of
the above and maybe one more um which is
basically to to gain exposure and to
bring
another angle of innovation for png we
have
really the
the brightest minds in png in our r d
function in our it function in all of
our functions but we also know that
there are so many
bright minds uh outside of png and
uh we won't be able to invent everything
ourselves and there is a lot of
openness for open innovation sure for
things that are being invented outside
interesting and so when you're when
you're finding yourself
at this sort of this intersection you
have the startup like modify or grin or
or some other companies that you're
involved with and then you have png
the leadership the mid management and
the ex and the executioners inside
where do you find yourself in this whole
spectrum i mean what do you even do in
the day-to-day right um that's a great
question i need to think about it myself
no kidding um so basically i
personally i think i have the best job
in the world because uh what i do is
basically doing that before a few times
i know i know basically
part of my role or half of my role is
externally facing and that means
meeting
the most interesting startups in a very
wide variety of literally looking for
the most interesting companies that will
be
that are early stage that will suit png
right which is right anything and it's
it's almost anything so i'm i'm looking
from data analytics startups cyber
enterprise infrastructure on the one
hand and then on the other hand femtech
wellness
sustainability supply chain so many
things because it can be either to help
png's 100 000 person company be
healthier right cyber analytics et
cetera et cetera or it can also be how
do we actually take sense digitization
and anybody who's listening here can
just imagine what are the opportunities
if png is able to harness
digitization exactly come on it's crazy
right right especially as png is
actually the largest perfumer in the
world i did not know that right yeah now
as you so you meet a company like that
we meet great researchers saying okay
we're starting we're we're running on
the company and now you're saying okay i
see a potential here i think this is
interesting yeah there's a bunch of
different and maybe the the the perfume
division didn't even tell you yet right
that they need your help right but but
you're you're making this connection
yeah what do you do how do you bring
that to an investment right so that's
that's the other half basically yeah the
role is internally facing and that's
i think first and foremost is is
understanding what are the challenges of
the business units and in order to do
that you need to be
very much involved with the business
because if you are being seen and being
seen as someone external they will
probably not share with you their their
real challenges so you need for them to
feel like orr is here with us he's one
of us not just or but the team yeah the
innovation is an integral part of of of
their team and of their success yeah
because at the end of the day we are a
team we're a multifunctional team um and
we were very much embedded within the
business units is it hard to create that
intimacy that trust within you and the
business unit it's all about
relationship at the end it's all about
relationship uh but still you haven't
talked to some of these people for maybe
a year and all of a sudden you're
reaching out saying hey i have this cool
opportunity right um it's um 100 000
people yeah well we don't work with all
the 100 000 but but still um
i think very very uh important aspect of
it is
is uh creating or gaining credibility
and you do that by you know quick queens
and you know the small things
um and you know step by step you're
you're creating that uh
that trust right that's credibility
within uh within the teams and only at
that point you can achieve you know
greater uh greater things
i want to take a step back and uh go
back to the three prerequisites that i
uh told you about so i was actually um
[Music]
i wouldn't say lying but i was bluffing
a bit okay so it's not only three
percent privileges
so basically once those three
prerequisites are met we then meet with
a business unit and we brainstorm
together with them
um
usually between two and three hours and
the the
end goal or the the outcome of that
brainstorming is something that we call
an innovation brief or a one-pager rfp
um
what have you and basically the the
content of that that um
document is you know general background
about the the problem what it is that
we're looking for and also what we're
not looking for so on the one hand
we don't want it to be too narrow
because we don't want to miss
opportunities and on the other end we
don't want to be too wide so we won't be
able to uh you know to uh
um find the the needle in the the stay
hack
uh haystack so
um once we've completed those uh three
prerequisites and the brainstorming i
then go back to the vp
and i'm telling her actually there are
not only three
prerequisites there are two more so
one is uh define what success look like
or in other words sounds important yeah
in other words kpis yeah right because
um
i want to avoid the situation where you
know the the business unit has defined
or um
you know
tasked the the startup with providing
10x of something they provided 10x and
then i'll go back to the business and
they say hey all right great so can we
scale
and then they'll tell me
ah we don't know
we're not sure let us think about it
maybe next year no no if the startup
delivered 10x
we continue to scale
again between us
i don't care about pocs
i honestly don't care about pcs i mean
besides you know a nice tap on on my
back i don't care about it
what i care about is successful pocs
that have scaled within the company that
have created an impact and it and maybe
it's 10x for one person but it could be
5x for another person and the third
person is only know it's even if it's 2x
or 1.5x exactly it's worth it for us
exactly but you can't have that
conversation if you don't agree to
define what success is in the first
place exactly what does the organization
need okay so that's one prerequisite
right and the second or the fifth
depends uh how you we'll go with the
second because we're in the next phase
already all right so the second is
basically
budget for the sake of scaling
now unlike the budget let's say for the
poc for the poc you know 50k i'll demand
sort of a wire transfer yeah right yeah
in this stage um
it's you know it's
it's very undefined so uh the vp doesn't
know and neither do i we sure we haven't
even chosen the startup yet so we have
no idea how much budget will be needed
for the sake of scaling but what i do
want to hear from her is yes oh if if we
find the right startup and the the pilot
is successful i have sufficient budget
for the sake of scaling and all this
goes back to the first question is this
a must-have
problem or a nice draft because if it's
a master they'll have the budget right
so that so it sounds like the first one
the first of the two was
let's make sure we are coherent and what
we're trying to achieve here right given
that i find a startup that is able to
fulfill this definition
we will approach to scale which is what
i measure myself as or by my ability to
scale within png right and the second
one is let's just also make sure that
you have the willingness and you have
the capacity to do it if we choose to
exactly exactly and that that it sounds
that's a little bit more conceptual than
than tangible but but it still gives you
that that
that uh understanding of okay it's
possible and right there is willingness
right and actually what what we're doing
here is we're doing we're pre-vetting
our corporate for the startups
because again we realize that their most
important asset is their time yeah
um and in the end it creates a a win-win
for everyone because we didn't waste the
time of the business unit not for the
startups and not for us as well and it
sounds pretty healthy so you actually
measure yourself by
your ability to stand and to meet
what the business units exactly have
have have articulated very clearly this
is our kpi
and you help them get there right that's
that's the circle here because you know
i
the the question of how uh innovation
managers at corporates are being
measured it's probably one of the most
challenging questions in the open
innovation space yeah um and you know we
can create
hundreds of pocs a year if if i decided
to be measured on pocs i could create
100 pocs each year but i would be
bluffing yeah because nothing would come
out of it right i prefer you're not very
impressive yes but nothing would happen
for png and i wouldn't waste the time
for all the startups and and i would
create an uh
an immense damage for png's reputation
within the ecosystem right and we all
knows you know we all know that uh news
spread fast and bad news spread faster
yeah right so
it's very very important that this
pre-vetting uh
uh process to make sure that we're not
we're not wasting their time so i would
prefer to only have even four pocs yeah
but for pocs where i'm sure that they
have a very strong potential sure to
succeed and to scale and create an
impact right so that and and that means
that a startup that actually gets to a
poc stage with you
from your perspective you already you've
done the pre-vetting and you basically
can tell them like guys listen if this
works we're in yeah i mean and we've
articulated what needs to happen exactly
do they understand the the amount of
work and process that you're that you've
made yeah towards that no they they
definitely do and i think uh i think
they they cherish that and and they
acknowledge that and yeah
i mean we're seeing you know our our
success rates are are pretty high due to
that yeah um
so again it's it creates a win-win but
not actually not only for them but for
their investors as well sure i think one
of the reasons uh
you know that the top vc's in the world
love to work with with png is because of
that
value we we create for them and and for
their portfolio companies
so i want to go back to
to one of the original statements okay
why why is this the best job in the
world for you
if you really look at yourself and and i
mean assuming a blue ocean of
opportunities you can do anything i mean
why is this
sort of the bread and butter of who you
are right now right well as you uh
recall i i uh
describe myself as an infinite period
learner um and for me i have a job where
i'm actually getting paid to
see and and meet with the most
interesting people worldwide really the
top researchers
each of them in in their own field and
the top startups in a really really wide
variety of areas
so it's not that i only see cyber
startups every day i see cyber i see
wellness i see femtech so it's my no day
looks like the the other so it's it's
very uh
um very different and and
and very uh inspirational each each and
every day i love it i love the north
star i'm an infinitely curious
and and this is a place where i actually
get paid to be infinitely curious right
and so it's and it just sounds like
you're so you're so coherent and and how
do i actually create meaningful value
for the organization and and and you
understand the different stakeholders
you understand some of the pitfalls and
the sensitivities but but you also at
the end make sure to put yourself
accountable
that at the end of the year you want to
see did i meet the kpis of the business
units exactly which translate to how png
is going to be a better company exactly
which is which is not trivial yeah
oh thank you very very much thank you
this was so much fun i love this
and the best of luck with png and with
continuing to push you know the
boundaries of the of what innovation is
and how these companies can work
together with the ecosystem and the
ecosystem is very very lucky to have you
so thank you thank you